Salut à tous c'est Pêcheur de trésors
Oh non qu'est-ce qu'il fait Baptiste ?
Il commence les bêtises déjà
Dès l'introduction
aujourd'hui en est encore au bord du canal
pour de la pêche à l'aimant
Et là, on a repéré quelque chose.
Baptiste va le récupérer
Pour moi, c'est un sac à main.
Non, non, non,
un sac, c'est quand même un sac.
Un sac cabas mais vide
Dommage.
On va voir ce qu'on peut trouver
On a déjà fait cet endroit
il y a environ un an.
L'idée, c'est de voir si ça c'est rempli de nouveau
En tout cas c'est très très vaseux
T'as trouvé quelque chose là au bord ?
Oui sous 10 centimètres de vase
Il vient, regarde les bulles
C'est un truc de fou
comme ça bulle
Ça fait un bon bruit, un bruit de coffre
Ouais.
Je pense que c'est un coffre,
mais il faut réussir à le travailler
Oh ben là, tu vas y arriver
Alors ça bulle énormément
et ça fait un bruit creux
On regarde un portable, portable cassé
téléphone de dealer ou de criminel.
Oh une boîte
Non une caisse de monnaie
comme une caisse d'argent
Elle est ouverte
Malheureusement
On va regarder quand même
Dommage.
Dommage
Il y a peut être les pièces en dessous.
OK, c'est bon signe.
En cinq minutes de pêche.
Elle était tellement sous la vase
Faut vraiment pas hésiter à creuser
Là typiquement faut emmener Wim avec la perche. Oui,
mais là pour aller là dedans...
Compliqué
Ici
Il y avait un truc
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
Audio sonic stéréo.
Énorme et il y a peut être une cassette dedans.
Attends
Je pense qu'il
y a une cassette à l'intérieur
c'est pas trop de notre génération,
mais on connaît quand même.
Un petit Walkman
Je continue de pêcher à l'aimant
mais je vous l'ouvrira et on va regarder
s'il y a une cassette à l'intérieure,
ça peut être très drôle.
Ça peut être très drôle.
Ça, c'est des choses
qu'on avait loupées parce que celle là,
elle est dans l'eau depuis longtemps.
Oui. Mais par contre, c'est dingue
la façon dont la vase préserve
la qualité des objets.
Parce que là le truc il est encore neuf.
Il est comme neuf.
Le lecteur de cassettes
en vrai avec la perche là tu te régales
Même d'en haut
Sans rentrer dans l'eau
Ah oui, les bulles, les bulles,
les bulles
Vous êtes prêt ?
Ça vient je crois
Tu paris sur quoi ? Un cadre de moto ?
C'est incroyable de voir toutes ces bulles
Il y a une partie creuse
Un coffre fort !
Envois ton aimant s'il te plait.
Ça commence bien aujourd'hui !
alors
J'essaie de l'envoyer là
En même temps
pour les attraper.
Il semble ouvert un peu à droite
Je suis bloqué
Moi aussi, c'est pas grave
Vas dessous
Il est un peu lourd quand même
Il est rempli de vase
Attend, il se vide
C'est pas top
C'est un coffre encastré je crois
Il est ancien
Il faudra le vider sur la terre, là bas au fond
Regardez ce coffre !
Il doit être dans l'eau depuis longtemps
Il est beau
Essaie de ne pas trop salir la route
Ça fait plaisir, ça fait plaisir.
Troisième lancer à peu près et une caisse et un coffre.
Ça commence très bien.
Je suis plein de vase
on va quand même regarder un peu
Il a pris cher
Il est mort
Il ne devait pas être si facile à ouvrir avant
C'est un peu sale tout ça
On continuera à la maison avec le tuyau
C'est trop sale
En plus il fait chaud, on ne verra rien
C'est un papier ou une pochette ?
Une pochette, tu peux la rincer
Je vais rincer ça, mais je pense
que c'est juste une pochette plastique.
C'est une pochette, peut être pour mettre
les permis de conduire, les anciens formats
Vous trouvez des trucs ?
Ouais, on a fait un coffre fort
et une caisse
Ouais, c'est pas mal
Encore un téléphone cassé.
C'est le fameux F2.
Là c'est toujours les mêmes,
les téléphones les moins chers.
C'était le F1 que tu avais trouvé
Aussi du calibre douze,
mais c'est juste de la douille.
Quand tu pêches à l'aimant et que tu vois ça,
c'est que c'est bon signe.
Allez, on va voir ce que c'est.
Je crois que j'ai un morceau qui vient.
Trempe le encore il est trop sale
J'ai peur de le perdre.
C'est un morceau de caddie je crois
Quoi que
Un antivol
Finalement, c'était pas si cool
Non ? Peut mieux faire.
Allez, on va continuer.
Regarde ça,
c'est la technique quand il y a beaucoup de vase.
J'ai reçu de l'eau
Pardon
Il a bien mangé.
Ouais, ça va.
Il a mangé du saucisson, du jambon,
du fromage.
Parfait
Du paté
Un repas complet
Il a tout goûté, il donnait la patte, il s'asseyait
Ah pour de la bouffe oui
Non !
Tu as jeté quoi ?
Le lecteur cassette que tu voulais ouvrir
Le lecteur cassette ? Tu as intérêt à le retrouver
Direct !
Tu l'as sauvé
Une munition de calibre 12
Et qui cette fois ci est pleine.
Pourtant, c'est la même couleur que les autres.
Plus intéressant.
C'est pas la même longueur, c'est bon signe
Il y a du cuivre là
Qu'est ce que c'est que ce machin ?
Il y a des boutons,
ça a l'air vachement ancien.
Si vous avez un commentaire
C'est un appareil électrique.
Un bout que je travaille
depuis longtemps et il vient.
Finalement, il n'est pas si lourd.
Oula !
On dirait un peu ce qu'il ne faut pas
pêcher
Non ça va, c'est un pot d'échappement
J'ai eu peur
Moi aussi
On a cru que c'était un gros obus
Il n'y a pas de raisons ici.
Non, il n'y a pas de raison dans le Sud
C'est un vieux pot.
Ça fait un moment qu'il est là.
Il fait son lavement comme dirait Quentin.
Et voilà !
La trouvaille du chef
Bien joué
Il faut vraiment y aller avec les perches
Ouais là c'est trop
On va les commander
D'ailleurs, si vous voulez un aimant, nous utilise les Barbarian de chez Maison de la Détection
Celui là c'était le plus puissant, il peut tirer jusqu'à 1600 kilos.
Et vous avez le code promo
PECHEURDETRESORS
qui vous offre - 5% sur toute la boutique,
Que se soit sur les aimants ou les détecteurs de métaux.
Comme on dit avec Quentin,
Ils vendent aussi des perches qui permettent de sonder les canaux comme celui là
Salut
Je sent qu'il va venir.
Il fait une sacrée quantité de bulles ton truc Quentin
Franchement, c'est trop bizarre
T'as un morceau
Un bout de guidon,
peut être encore du vélo
C'est tellement sale
Encore des bouts de vélo
C'est un vélo qui a 30 ans
Tu veux leur donner  la ferraille ?
On n'en a pas assez pour l'instant.
C'est des cartons
Ouais, ça vaut cher aussi.
Ah, ça y est !
C'est ça en fait, ils tombent en miettes sous mon aimant
Il doit être dans l'eau depuis très longtemps lui
Un sachet
Ça ça fait plaisir.
Alors est ce que le sachet était déjà là
de base ?
Oui, oui, c'est vraiment dans le sachet
Des munitions je crois
Ah ! C'est bon ça
Du calibre 12
Ouais avec des grosses ogives
Ah oui, oui, ce n'est pas de la grenaille ni de le chevrotine
C'est des vrais munitions, ça fait des dégâts.
Attention, il y a une voiture
Cool un sac de munition, ça faisait longtemps
Ca fait plaisir, c'est bon signe.
Une belle trouvaille, bien joué
Il y en a combien ? Un, deux, trois,
quatre, cinq, six, sept, huit, neuf, neuf.
Ils ont tirés avec la 10ᵉ
Sympa
bien joué.
Allez, ça motive ça. Du coup, on continue.
Oui, une clé
C'est des clés de voiture
Il semblerait.
Volkswagen
Dragon, ça, c'est un portail,
Volkswagen ouais
Pas mal
Le fameux fil de pêche
Il y a le plomb
C'est déjà pas mal
Qu'est ce que tu as pêché de beau
C'est bon, je l'ai arraché
Il faut les perches
Prochaine fois en tenue de plongée, pour la partie 2
Vaccins contre les égoutiers aussi.
Contre les égoutiers.
Faut toujours se méfier des égoutiers.
Ca mord
On est un peu frustrés par cet endroit
parce qu'on sent énormément d'objets,
qu'on n'arrive
pas à sortir avec nos aimants
Il y a environ 50cm d'épaisseur
de vase, plus d'algues.
Donc l'idée, c'est
qu'on va revenir sur une période telle
que l'hiver
ou y aura déjà beaucoup moins d'algues.
Et surtout,
on va commander des perches
De chez Maison de la détection
pour pouvoir sonder la vase
plus en profondeur et on va descendre
dans l'eau avec des combinaisons.
Chose promise, chose due,
nous voilà de retour
Avec Wim et Danny, qui sont venus
spécialement de Hollande pour nous aider.
Mais voilà, ce sont des spécialistes
des bâtons
maintenant, ce qu'on va faire,
c'est qu'on va aller dans l'eau,
on va aller dans l'eau pourquoi ?
Pour sortir tout ce qui est coincé
sous la vase ?
On sait qu'il y a énormément de choses.
Vous l'avez vu dans la dernière vidéo,
on était coincés sur plein de trucs.
Aujourd'hui,
on va venir et on va les sortir.
Wim a aussi lancé sa chaine
Elle sera en description, n'hésitez pas à regarder
Il trouve des folies sous l'eau
Aux Pays-Bas, en Belgique
Oui aucun soucis, par contre je parle anglais
Bien sûr, il parle en anglais dans les vidéos
Même si vous ne parlez pas anglais, vous pouvez voir ses belles découvertes
On peut regarder même sans parler anglais, c’est visuel
J’essaie de parler anglais mais je suis néerlandais, pardonnez moi si je fais des fautes
Il n'y a pas de problème, c'est un anglais simple
On n'envoie toujours le plus grand d'abord
Je vais les rejoindre
J’ai quelque chose
Danny a quelque chose
Il y a vraiment beaucoup de vase
C’est bon signe pour trouver les objets anciens
Voilà la première trouvaille
je pensais avoir une caisse de monnaie mais non
C'est du cuivre
Une pièce, bravo : Du franc
Une ancienne pièce française
ça commence bien
Elle est plus jeune que Danny
J’ai aussi 5 centimes d’euros
On n'est pas bien là ?
Rasta ? Comment ça va ?
Il se demande un peu ce qu'on fait je crois
Ca vient d’une voiture
C’est ça qui est bien en allant dans l’eau, tu trouves tous les objets y compris non magnétiques
Je pense que j’ai quelque chose de lourd
Regarde le sourire de Dany
Un coffre fort !! Génial !
Le premier coffre fort du jour
On l’ouvre dans l’eau ?
Il y a quelque chose de rouge à l’intérieur
Oh pardon
On va vérifier ?
Il est lourd
Danny, le premier coffre fort dans le sud de la France
Ouvrons le
Pour des bijoux
Pour des boucles d'oreilles
Une trouvaille ?
Il est vide
Le million d'euros ! Le million d'euros !
Le prochain sera le bon
Mais c’est bon signe, puis c’est le début, un coffre fort en 5 minutes
Super ! Un coffre fort en 5 minutes
On va retourner dans l'eau, nos perches nous attendent
Rasta, mets toi à l'ombre
Assis
C'est bien
Ok, on va vérifier l'aimant
On a une pièce encore
Du Franc
Quelle année cette fois-ci ?
La dernière année des Francs
Bonjour
Elle est bonne
Vous êtes au détecteurs ?
Avec des aimants
Trop bien
Elle est vide ou pleine ? Vide
C'est quand même bon signe, du calibre 12
Qu’est-ce que tu as trouvé ?
Tu veux faire la grosse commission ?
C’est pas normal ça
J’ai quelque chose d’autre ici
C’est une vraie découverte bizarre
Ici j’ai un truc mais je dois aller sous l’eau
Un pneu !
Je ne suis pas fatigué pourtant pour l’instant
Bien joué, tu veux que je prenne les toilettes ?
Tu peux prendre les toilettes ou le pneu
Ils sont propres maintenant
On va s’en servir après pendant la pause
Oui on pourra s’asseoir dessus
Tu y arrives ?
Un enjoliveur
Peugeot
J’ai quelque chose ici aussi
Un ordinateur portable ?
HP Compact
Je regarde si on peut l’ouvrir
Il y a un truc ici
Jolie découverte
Et c’est bien de sortir ça de l’eau
Regarde la batterie
Peut-être qu’on peut regarder Pêcheur de Trésors
Oui et vous abonner à la chaîne de Wim
Tu as des bras plus longs que moi
Juste ici
On peut l’attraper je crois
Oh attends
Tu peux me tenir ça ?
Je vais plonger
Je vais l’avoir
C’est grand
Oh un panneau
On peut s’en servir
ça veut dire que tu coupes l’herbe
Ah ok mais nous on ne fait pas ça
On nettoie les rivières
J’ai un câble
Et du calibre 12 mais vide
Wim est sur quelque chose de gros
ça vient
C’est gros
Un énorme cadre
Peut-être qu’il vient d’une grande moto
Je suis content que le moteur n’y soit pas
Un énorme cadre de moto
Vous allez réussir a le sortir ?
Je ne sais pas
C’est assez lourd
je vais sauter
Bien !!
Elle a passé un moment dans la vase
Celle là, il fallait aller la chercher
Il y a encore la chaîne
Oui donc c’était une moto
On va continuer, on a fait une toute petite partie et on a déjà plein de choses
Même après avoir pêché à l'aimant ici
Il y a toujours moyen de trouver des trucs
Wim qui plonge là dedans, il est un peu fou
J’ai quelque chose
C'est assez lourd
Un morceau de voiture
Oui je pense
On peut chercher de l’or avec ça
Regarde
Tu ne sais pas ce qu’elle contient
C’est une clef USB
Qu'est ce qu'il y a dessus ?
Je pense qu’elle contient la sextape de KIM k
Tu la mettras dans le riz
Ou quelques bitcoins
Oh oui, qui sait ? !
Ok alors on le mettra dans le riz
Peut-être que durant d’autres pêches à l’aimant on a déjà trouvé des disques durs qui contenaient des Bitcoins
Et on les a jetés
Oui  c’est sûr
Peut-être même dans l’ordinateur portable
Oui c’est ce que je pense
Je crois que j'ai quelque chose
Oui j’ai quelque chose
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est
Peut-être que ça vient d’un scooter, pour tenir droit
Une béquille de scooter
Il est complètement fou
Mais celui-ci est cassé je crois
Un autre toilette
Il y a une collection de toilettes
C’est parfait on peut tous faire caca a la fin
Ah du béton
Un morceau de voiture
Il y a peut être un vélo à trouver ici
Je continue à chercher
Là je pense avoir quelque chose
Ca vient encore du vélo
Et du calibre 12
Celle-ci est pleine
Elle est pleine, c'est bon signe
Wim a quelque chose là bas, en face
C'est un petit tabouret
C'est des lentilles d'eau, il parait que ca se mange, je n'en ai jamais gouté
Dites moi en commentaire si vous en avez déjà gouté
Wow ! C'est une bouteille
Elle est ancienne
Un pot d’échappement
Mais nous ne sommes pas fatigués
Un petit pot d'échappement
Celui là est dans l'eau depuis longtemps
Wim a quelque chose
Des morceaux de voitures
J’ai un safe (coffre fort)
Safe (ty belt) ceinture de sécurité, jeu de mot très drôle, Bravo Wim
La ceinture de sécurité
Ici il y a presque 1 mètre de vase
C'est incroyable
J'ai jamais plongé dans un endroit avec autant de vase
Oh le débile
Je viens de mettre ma casquette dans l'eau
Peut-être qu’on peut reconstituer le puzzle
Rasta va être super content
Des os, il y a plein d'os
Laissez un commentaire si vous savez quel type d'animale ca peut être
Est-ce que vous allez trouver la tête ?
Regardez
Il a trouvé un téléphone
Pêcheur de Trésors et Wims treasure adventures
C’est bien, c’est un modèle sympa !
Peut-être que la carte mémoire est encore à l’intérieur
Ah on peut peut-être vérifier alors
Il l'a trouvé à la main, j'ai les bras trop court pour faire ça
Ah, une jante
Danny a trouvé une nouvelle jante
J'espère qu'il n'y a pas trop de crocodiles ici
Je n'ai pas vérifié avant si il y en avait
Il fait que de sortir des jantes, c'est bon pour le poids au ferrailleur
Une sorte de latte
Une autre munition qui est pleine
Au même endroit
On va essayer de trouver d'où viennent les munitions
C'est la deuxième pleine que je fais ici
Il y a surement un sac quelque part
Si vous voulez des perches, on les retrouves sur le site de Maison de la Détection
Des perches de marque Magnetar
La même marque que les aimants
Vous pouvez même rajouter une rallonge, je peux vous dire que ça fait le taff
Aujourd'hui j'ai ajouté l'aimant Barbarian mais on peut ajouter l'importe quel aimant
Nos amis hollandais le font avec le Beast et le Terror
Ca se fait avec n'importe quel type d'aimant
C'est pas très utile d'en avoir un très puissant, son but est surtout de repérer les objets
Là j'ai quelque chose par exemple
Wim a quelque chose aussi là bas
Il a quelque chose d'énorme
On dirait qu'il l'a
Un morceau de voiture ?
Une portière
Avec la fenêtre encore présente
Une portière entière
Dites nous en commentaire quelle type de voiture c'est
C’est lourd mec
mais elle est complète donc...
On peut la retourner
Je suis retourné à l'endroit des munitions
Je trouve plein de bouts de calibre 12
Ils sont coupés alors soit les munitions ont été découpées soit elles sont trop vieille
Je vais continuer par ici pour voir si je trouve d'autres munitions
Encore une ici
Tout ça c'est de la poudre
Elle n'a pas été récupéré, elles ont du se décomposer
Il a trouvé une autre portière
Wim a quelque chose
Il a une grosse portière
J'ai quelque chose aussi
C’est bien pour le mettre dans ton allée
Ne pas jeter de morceaux de voitures dans le canal
Oui oui mais regarde
Une autre porte !
Il faut qu’ils fassent un nouveau paneau
Celui-ci est ancien je pense
Cette portière est vieille
Je suis curieux, peut-être que des abonnés savent de quel voiture ça provient
Il y a beaucoup de vase ici
Il y a quelque chose d’autre ici
Une guitare
C’est incroyable
Et ça avec l’aimant tu ne peux pas le trouver
Tu pourras jouer de la guitare ce soir
C’est un petit canapé je crois
Ou alors c’est la banquette d’une vieille voiture
Nous on va faire une petite pause et on reprend